[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und jetzt bekommen
bei einem neuen video ja doch ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut
das mikrofon an wartet kurz ja ich habe
mir für heute wirklich mal was ganz
besonderes wieder verlegt weil ich habe
gesehen so meine videos youtube videos
mit nur likes musicals wie gesperrt
wurden also was das kommt echt mal
richtig gut an und ich bin mal auf die
idee gekommen joecks ich schau doch mal
ob es auch youtube videos gibt die hat
von youtube so gesperrt wurden gebannt
wurden weil sie halt gegen irgendwelche
richtlinien verstoßen oder halt
irgendwelche urheberrechtsverletzung
also war oder vielleicht auch
irgendwelche total großen skandale
ja ich habe ein bisschen gut und ich bin
auch wirklich fündig geworden ich habe
einige videos gefunden die halt zum teil
gerodet wurden aber halt wirklich mit
richtig krass und service also es lohnt
sich an dieser stelle ich sag das echt
selten aber heute lohnt ist ich will
dich mal dran zu bleiben vorher war ich
allerdings noch kurz fragen komme ich
kann das wirklich nicht verstehen
natürlich betrifft das jetzt nicht jeden
von euch aber es betrifft echt viele
weil ich denke mir so hier widerspricht
euch einfach nehmen wir das jetzt nicht
böse oder sonne aber ich habe euch ja so
vor ungefähr 12 monaten ein neues intro
gezeigt dieses mit der komischen figur
hier mal kurz ein kurzer ausschnitt
[Musik]
und dann sofort alle drei alex ist
interessiert scheiße das ist übelst
gruselig und so und diese kommentare
hatten dann auch wirklich immer top
kommentar dann in tristan in tristan
irgendwann habe ich dann gesagt okay
wenn ihr das intro wirklich nicht mit
wenn ihr euch nicht dran gewöhnen können
dann nehmen wir das halt wieder raus so
entress raus und plötzlich ändert
wirklich jeder von euch seine meinung
oder die meisten zumindest und ich hab
da kommentare mit 2000 likes dass das
intro doch bitte wieder kommen soll wo
ich mir denke das macht doch gar keinen
sinn ok bisschen runterkommen ich wollte
euch eigentlich nur fragen jetzt zum
allerletzten mal schreibt mir doch mal
bitte in die kommentare
ob ihr dieses intro und das war jetzt
wird nur ein kurzer ausschnitt also ob
ihr das noch haben wollt oder nicht
schreibt einfach ja oder schreibt ein
und bitte ändert morgen ja nicht wieder
eure meinung
ansonsten schreibt es dazu dass das
schwankt so jetzt aber zurück zum thema
jetzt sagen wir fanden vor dann
youtube-videos die gesperrt wurden
ich wünsche euch viel spaß und ich habe
hunger ich habe richtig hunger gerade
also wir fangen jetzt hier mit einem
video an
ihr seht das ja hier ist halt irgendwann
man denkt erst mal eine frau aber nein
das soll wohl dein typ sein und das ist
finde ich echte gruselige und echt
kranke story vielleicht nur eine kurze
vorgeschichte also es geht dabei um den
youtube der teil 2 youtube channel auf
dem eigentümer hat er einfach also er
hat halt immer so hohe schuhe an so
typische frauen schuhe wenn man mal raus
geht abends und sich schick mal wie man
ja auch hier sehen kann so schuhe mit
absätzen und jetzt gerade hat man ja
gesehen wie er halt so ein apfel
zerdrückt hat einfach mit diesen schuhen
ist ja nix dabei wie man darauf kommt
weiß ich nicht die haben wir jetzt auch
erstmal einen vermeintlichen anderen
youtuber der hat auch hohe schuhe anhat
also musste erstmal eine verbindung
herstellen können ich habe euch ja eben
schon gesagt ein typ mit zwei channel
er hat allerdings nicht auf dem ein
schöner gesagt dass ja noch diesen
schritt hat und der hat auf dem anderen
schon launig gesagt dass er noch diesen
journal und das war wirklich ein sehr
kranker mensch ich habe hier die
original zähne
ihr könnt euch jetzt vorstellen was er
in diesem video vor hat wenn er in dem
anderen video den apfel zerdrückt hat es
hört sich mega krank kann aber der typ
hat halt sondern fetisch wir machen
einfach mal kurz weiter
so mehr werde ich gar nicht zeigen ihr
habt die wahrscheinlichkeit gesehen er
hat gerade beinahe die schnecke
zertreten und der fetisch dieses mannes
lag wohl darin halt einfach kleine
hilflose lebewesen mit so hohen absatz
schon zu zertreten dieser youtube
channel ist irgendwie gut 66 und ein
nutzer hat halt diesem hintergrund auf
einem anderen video feststellen können
wodurch ja dann halt ermittelt werden
konnte er wurde youtube gemeldet
angezeigt natürlich alle videos wurden
gelöscht und erstmal heute eine sperre
dass er keine youtube views mehr
hochladen kann er diesen auszug habe ich
jetzt irgendwo im internet gefunden
wir können nur noch kurz ein bisschen
weiter gucken aber also wirklich total
krank wenn youtube video was gesperrt
wurde ist auch richtig so sollte man
sich nicht angucken was in den köpfen
von solchen menschen vorgeht will ich
gar nicht wissen wie macht man weiter
mit einem deutschen youtube video was
soweit ich weiß auch von youtube bzw
einem musiklabel er halt gesperrt wurde
ist auch noch gar nicht so lange her
allerdings habe ich wirklich erst
gestern zum ersten mal gehört weil ich
das gar nicht wusste vom youtube aks
free keinen respekt mehr ja ich hab mir
das gestern ganz mal angehört das hat
irgendwelche ria planung das hat auch da
wirklich schon unfassbare 4 millionen
klicks wir haben einfach mal kurz rein
[Musik]
was mache ich mit 1 2 millionen
ich habe also influenza marketing das
ist youtube germany steht dem ist nur
baby heißt soviel dazu also vielleicht
erstmal meine eigentliche meinung so
krieg ich gucke jetzt nicht auf seine
videos aber ab und zu schaue ich da auch
mal rein und man kann das halten was man
will aber ich finde eigentlich
unterhaltsam was seine musik angeht also
an sich ist es ja so ein youtube musiker
den man jetzt nicht wirklich sofort
ernst nimmt als musiker allerdings war
ich von diesem song wo ich ihn gestern
hat das erste mal gehört hab wirklich
überzeugt sollte vor allem vom refrain
hat mir richtig gut gefallen irgendein
anderes von ihm finde ich auch wirklich
cool also es kann nicht wirklich mir
anhören und es gefällt mir dann gibt es
natürlich auch sonst von ihnen die ich
nicht so mag
aber dieser die jetzt an der stelle
finde ich cool auch vor allem im
internet gebe ich recht ich meinen
ersten youtuber zwei millionen abos und
man weiß halt irgendwann wie das system
so läuft man vielleicht was machen
sollte um möglichst viel aufmerksamkeit
zu bekommen das ist ja an sich das ziel
von youtube an möglichst viel
aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen ist ja an
sich kein geheimnis ist sicherlich auch
mein ziel mit dem youtube video das ich
gerade mache wirklich viele leute zu
erreichen
nur wenn man dann halt leider cloud von
jemanden aus keine ahnung england kam
mir glaube ich habe halt echt leider
geklaut auch wenn der mega geil ist wenn
man es dann als ein eigenen werk
darstellt ist es natürlich fragwürdig
und somit auch gerechtfertigt dass es
halt runter genommen wurde an sich ist
natürlich schade weil mir der song echt
ganz gut gefällt und sicherlich auch
viel arbeit drin steckt aber so ist das
ja wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
video was auch gesperrt wurde bzw der
ganze kanal wurde gesperrt sowie schauen
wir ein
ich muss schon mal kurz stoppen also als
ich sie zum ersten mal gesehen habe auch
wenn ich sie jetzt noch sehe ich finde
die sich so gruselig aus die kanzlerin
horrorfilm einfach auch so eine straße
stellen wären kranke horrorfilm
ihr könnt ja mal kurz in die kommentare
schreiben was schätzt wie alt war sie
hier als sie das aufgenommen hat also
für mich sieht wirklich aus wie
höchstens 13 sagen wir nennen 13
höchstens lee ist allerdings schon 17
oder 18 jahre alt auf diesem video
ich finde das so gruselig was war da
gerade von geräuschen winter wurden so
wir müssen das war auch gar nicht weiter
schauen
da verbirgt sich nämlich auch eine echte
story hinter ich hab so ein bisschen
gegoogelt eins zu eins im detail
wiedergeben kann ich das jetzt natürlich
nicht weil das meiste gar nicht auf
deutsch fall also die meisten quellen
dazu waren halt auf englisch und es war
noch sehr sehr viele informationen das
einzige was ich halt so daraus entnehmen
konnte die hieß halt irgendwie wie los
angeles oder so keine ahnung ein mädchen
mit asiatischen wurzeln oder so und sie
hat sich halt immer so als barbie
gekleidet wie man das halt auch sehen
konnten im video und ihre mutter hat sie
wollen immer so ein bisschen dazu
angestiftet hat youtube videos zu machen
sie sollte das machen wir auch recht
erfolgreich der channel ist sogar
mittlerweile wieder online nur die
mutter musste sie auch traurigerweise
man vor ganz vielen älteren männern
beschützen mit pädophilen absichten hat
einfach weil sich so jung aussieht und
dann dauern von solchen komischen
menschen angeschrieben wurde die hat
sich allerdings wohl mit 17 mal mit
einem getroffen der irgendwie sieben
jahre älter war denen sie dann auch nach
einer zeit geheiratet hat und dann ist
hier mit ihm wohl von zu hause abgehauen
und dann entstand sollen online beef
zwischen der mutter und ihr also möglich
ganz krank die haben damit den
heftigsten argumenten gegeneinander dass
ich wirklich öffentlich gestritten und
bereitet die mutter hatte auch irgendwas
mit youtube zu tun also ganz komisch ich
stimme vor meine mutter macht auch
youtube videos per und irgendwie hat die
mutter dann dem kanal die ganze zeit
gemeldet und so weiter weil sie halt die
mutter fragt mich nicht und youtube das
irgendwann erstmal gesperrt
der kanal war weg und viele hundert
tausend abonnenten auch anders dann
vorbei war und der tunnel wieder kiefer
kann ich euch nicht sagen allerdings
eine krasse story war ein riesiger
skandal vor allem im englischsprachigen
raum haben sehr viele menschen ist damit
bekommen alles so gut dass wir im
deutschsprachigen raum genug also
youtube haben die jetzt übernehmen genau
und wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
beitrag konnte ich mir auch nicht nehmen
lassen da mal genau zu recherchieren und
zwar geht es um den augen rollt skandal
der ja erst drei wochen oder soja ist
vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen
länger ich weiß es nicht vielleicht kurz
vorweg für die dies nicht mitbekommen
haben obwohl es bestimmt jeder von euch
mitbekommen hat er war irgendwo sonst
suicide foris unterwegs wo sich halt
menschen das leben nehmen und hat dort
eine leiche gefilmt das auf youtube
gestellt und das hatten riesigen skandal
ausgelöst das video wurde dann
wahrscheinlich hunderttausendfach
gemeldet allerdings habe ich mal gehört
dass es ist gar nicht unbedingt von
youtube sofort gesperrt wurde was ich
gar nicht verstehen kann weil es
eindeutig gegen die richtlinien
verstoßen weil du
menschen auf youtube präsentieren also
es kann auch gut sein dass es selber
gelöscht hat
genaueres wissen schreibt gängigen
kommentare es ist auf jeden fall ein
video was nicht mehr da und so dumm es
sich anhört man bilder natürlich auch
wissen warum das so ein riesiger skandal
ist was er da gefilmt hat und ich habe
im internet teil das originalvideo und
auch gefunden und halt irgendwas
zensierung ich habe gesehen auch eben
noch mal angucken das hier natürlich
nicht rein weil sonst ist dieses video
auf welches er klar
also ich weiß wirklich nicht wie man auf
die idee kommt sowas einfach hochzuladen
ich meine dass hier so viele kleine
kinder auch hat ja ein grund dass
irgendwelche filme wo halt menschen
umgebracht werden oder so erst ab 16
oder 18 sind warum dass ich sofort von
youtube gesperrt wurde
fragt mich nicht eigentlich hätte das
nach zehn minuten wieder weg sein soll
ich glaube er war der erfolgreichste
user 2017 hat ja innerhalb von einem
jahr 15 millionen abos gemacht weder
krank also man sollte auf jeden fall aus
fehlern lernen und das auf einsehen und
wir schauen jetzt nochmal das letzte
video an was ja auch noch gefunden habe
recording ob das vorhaben den eine
textur ist was des models die composite
whitney days before his home subscriber
server die connections der kurs ja diese
videos sind wirklich komplett weg es
handelt sich hier um irgend so ein ich
weiß nicht ob ich es verstanden hat das
war selber ein oder zusammenfassung von
irgendeinem englischen typen waren indes
player und blogger von dem wohl die
mutter gestorben ist er allerdings
nichts dagegen gemacht hat will jetzt
gar keine falschen infos zu übergeben
also ich gehe mal davon aus sie ist halt
einfach verstorben und in einem blog von
diesem typ haben dann halt welche von
seinen abonnenten diesen toten körper
wohl im hintergrund gesehen oder einen
vermeintlich toten körper worauf inhalt
die polizei alarmiert wurde und den
toten körper gefunden hat und das video
wurde dann logischerweise ebenfalls von
youtube runter genommen
man kann es auch nicht mehr finden ich
habe gesucht aber das war sowieso ein
relativ kleiner youtuber inwiefern das
hier in den medien und auf youtube irak
gegangen ist keine ahnung war der
deutsche traum wäre nicht von
betroffenen aber das waren jetzt zum
beispiel fünf youtube-videos die
gesperrt wurde oder ganze kanäle ich
würde sagen ich hoffe das video hat euch
gefallen und unterhalten last auf jeden
fall noch um da schon mal gespannt
vielleicht schafft nur 8000 wir auf
jeden fall bei instagram und snapshot
und wir sehen uns dann morgen schon
wieder
morgen gibt es wieder ein cooles video
zu meinem auto also leute haut rein